we are now just a few weeks away from
the first day of classes right here in
clark county
as thousands head back to school eight
news now is helping students
get what they need to succeed bianca
holman shows us how
you can take part in the school supply
drive that actually starts today
it's time to grab your backpacks because
kids will soon be walking into schools
just like this one here at james
mcmillan elementary school
many families were hit hard by the
pandemic and many still unemployed
so trying to fund school supplies may be
difficult eight news now is partnering
with smith to collect
school supplies for our community we
want to provide kids with tools they
need to be successful
starting today until july 29 supplies
will be collected to benefit the teacher
exchange
we're collecting things like backpacks
folders colored pencils clorox wipes and
you can drop
all those items off at any smith store
across the valley that includes
henderson
north las vegas and las vegas and of
course all this information is listed on
our website at eight 8newsnow.com
reporting bianca holman 8 news now